todos se declararon inocentes son los
policías que golpearon hasta la muerte
al joven de 29 años tyrine Nichols
actualmente los ex agentes están en
Libertad bajo fianza negaron su
culpabilidad ante los cargos de
asesinato en segundo grado asalto y
secuestró a grabados y opresión oficial
en la parte trasera de la sala estaba la
familia de Nichols quien a su vez era
padre de un niño de 4 años
sé que mi hijo se ha ido sé que nunca lo
volvería a ver
pero tenemos que empezar este proceso de
Justicia ahora mismo
y quiero que todos y cada uno de esos
policías puedan mirarme a la cara
todavía no han hecho eso
ni siquiera pudieron hacer eso hoy ni
siquiera tuvieron el coraje de mirarme a
la cara después de lo que le hicieron a
mi hijo
entonces me van a ver en cada cita en la
corte en cada una hasta que obtengamos
justicia para mi hijo
estoy aquí para asegurarme de que haya
justicia para nuestro hijo es un día
glorioso es el inicio del proceso
los ex policías deberán comparecer
nuevamente ante la justicia el primero
de mayo
eso fue muy emotivo y hubo muchas cosas
que no se dijeron en la sala del
tribunal hoy en el proceso
pero fue un día muy informativo a medida
que nos acercamos a la justicia
los acusados golpearon a nicoles tras un
control de tránsito sobre el que no está
Clara la causa de la detención tras ello
tuvo que ser hospitalizado y murió pocos
días después los cinco agentes fueron
despedidos tras una investigación
interna del pasado 26 de enero ante el
temor de una ola de rechazo a lo
sucedido similar a la que siguió a la
muerte de George Floyd en 2020 la
policía local también anunció la
disolución del escuadrón escorpión del
que formaban parte de los cuatro agentes
[Aplausos]